[Musique]
les élèves de terminale ont reçu leurs
résultats au baccalauréat éditions 2000
21 89 6 % des étudiants de l'académie de
versailles ont réussi leurs épreuves
sans passer par la case rattrapage pour
les autres la seconde chance avait lieu
du mercredi 7 à ce vendredi 9 juillet
résultats définitifs à suivre très
prochainement
la vaccination se poursuit dans les
yvelines tout au long de l'été quatre
centres resteront ouverts pour la
période estivale dans la crainte d'une
nouvelle vague est lié aux variations
des tas des mesures ont été prises pour
permettre la vaccination du plus grand
nombre
le délai entre deux injections et
dorénavant situés sur une fourchette
entre 21 et 40 9 jours des plages
d'ouverture des centres ont été étendues
et il n'est plus nécessaire de prendre
rendez vous au préalable
depuis deux semaines les jeunes se
réunissent par centaines le week end sur
la place du marché de versailles pour
des rassemblements appelé soirée projet
x problème c'est soirée dégénère souvent
jusqu'à se transformer en affrontements
entre borne ce qui suscite l'inquiétude
des riverains et commerçants
pas d'informations pour le moment autour
d'une troisième soirée pour ce week-end
france miniature fête ses 30 ans le parc
aux 117 monuments nationaux situés à
elancourt attire depuis sa création plus
de deux cent mille visiteurs par an pour
son anniversaire le parc offre la visite
à toutes les personnes qui partagent sa
date de naissance
l'année 1991 enfin du football alors que
l'euro se termine ce dimanche côté
transferts en yvelinois signe à
l'olympique de marseille
matteo guendouzi jeune international
français de 22 ans originaire de poissy
rejoint le club phocéen sous forme de
prêt avec une obligation d'achat estimée
à 11 millions d'euros
[Musique]